Madame la première ministre,
Ces derniers jours, nombre d'entre nous avons vu avec inquiétude
se multiplier sur les réseaux sociaux les tags antisémites
partout en France.
Cela nous rappelle avec horreur les temps de la peur
que nous croyions disparus.
Cette peur est ressentie par nombre de familles
de confession juive, avec la multiplication
des actes antisémites depuis le 7 octobre dernier. Pour l'année 2015,
nous déplorions 808 actes antisémites.
Au cours de ces trois dernières semaines, c'est 850 actes
qui ont été commis en France.
Plus de 6000 messages sur les réseaux sociaux ont fait l'objet
d'un signalement sur Pharos.
En réponse, 430 personnes ont été interpellées.
234 enquêtes ont été ouvertes.
La réponse de l'Etat est forte.
Nous la saluons.
Au-delà de la réponse pénale, nous, députés démocrates,
sommes alarmés sur ce que cette recrudescence
de l'antisémitisme dit de notre société.
Car l'antisémitisme agit comme un canari dans la mine.
La rabbin Delphine Horvilleur nous le rappelle,
"La frénésie antisémite révèle les failles de notre nation."
Dans l'esprit malade des antisémites,
les français de confession juive sont et ne seront
jamais que des juifs et non des citoyens.
Ce faisant, la passion antisémite s'attaque
au fondement même de notre nation.
L'antisémitisme est une insulte à notre histoire,
à nos principes républicains, à la cohésion nationale.
S'en prendre à un juif, c'est offenser la République,
c'est attaquer la France.
De la même façon, tout acte qui vise
à condamner l'autre, à l'agresser pour ce qu'il est,
pour sa religion, pour son origine,
est insupportable pour notre pays.
Madame la Première Ministre, face à ce fléau,
quelles réponses pouvons-nous apporter ?
non pas en tant qu'État, mais comme nation.
Je vous remercie.